hi I'm Erik Bosse in the lego movie -
the second part followed up the first
part with a really fun sequel that's
every bit as packed with cameos and
subtle animation jokes but with the
added bonus of some reflections about
how crazy it is that Chris Pratt's a
superhero now like I know some of the
fans who see it might be too young to
remember Andy Dwyer but not me that
Pratt for life let's rewatch this movie
scene by scene and point out all the
details that you might have missed it's
more than warning in case you haven't
seen the movie yet don't watch it I
think more people need to check this
movie out okay this movie begins by
revisiting the ending of the first film
with Will Ferrell as the man of stairs
inviting the sister to come play - which
manifests on the ground level as the
infamous Taco Tuesday attack on
bricksburg the aliens a planet DUPLO
totally dominate the heroes and notice
how they talk to each other the first
Legum will be revealed to be an
imaginative extended metaphor for the
relationship between the boy thin and
his father this second movie is about
Finn learning in a way to communicate
and cooperate with his sister Bianca
rather than just retreat in his own
gritty aggro mindset so down on the Lego
level the conflicts between these
characters often take the form of
arguments between kids miss me no I do
it I have a shield that shield doesn't
block measles how do you have measles
because my parents won't vaccinate me
Lucy aka wyldstyle voiced by Elizabeth
Banks tells us how the Justice League
took off and we hit return cameos from
all of them Superman
Channing Tatum Green Lantern Jonah Hill
Wonder Woman Cobie Smulders and now this
new version of Aquaman actually voiced
by Jason Momoa himself
notice how he says my man and whoa like
he always does he also has the same jade
necklace that Arthur curry wears in that
movie and if you look behind them on
their ship you can see that they have
Lex Luthor caged up makes sense that
they wouldn't want to leave him behind
and after years and years of destruction
we see how bricksburg
has evolved on the sign the BR collapse
making it expert this is similar to a
gag in a show Bojack horseman where the
D on the Hollywood sign went missing and
then all the vapid celebrities just
started calling at hollywoo Batman voice
actor Will Arnett stars in Bojack
horseman and that shows creator Raphael
bob-waksberg reportedly contributed to
this movie script this might've been one
of his jokes but the actual new name of
the city is epochal
Pittsburgh and it's inspired by many
famous post-apocalyptic settings of
course the world of Mad Max the battle
cars are modeled directly on the ones
from fury road and Larry the barista now
has an important Joe mask and Lucy's
look in her new black hand are a nod to
furiosa she also wears these goggles and
she's a hood a lot like the ones Ray
wears while scavenging the ruins of the
Star Destroyer on jakku in the force
awakens the wasted Statue of Liberty is
of course taken from the Planet of the
Apes and Batman's new leather straps
look a lot like the futuristic nightmare
version of Batman from Batman vs
Superman and then we catch up with Emmet
voiced by Chris Pratt's he follows his
same upbeat morning routine but the
surroundings have been updated the
coffee shop is now coffee unchained from
the coffee chain in the first movie
surfer Dave is now trade saw Dave and
Sherri scratching post returns but now
all of our cats have these
post-apocalyptic attire and while past
in all these familiar faces Emmitt
listens to a tween dream remix of
everything is awesome probably a nod to
Katy Perry's Teenage Dream and this
cover is by comedy music duo Garfunkel
and Oates Emmet also passes these sewer
babies which I guess are like the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles except
they're babies and they carry deadlier
weapons notice that one of them has a
Wolverine claw that's actually from the
Wolverine Lego set and it passes by
Alfred and Batman and he probably caught
a few of the references to his solo
spin-off movie a couple years ago the
other Justice League members said that
he was on a separate standalone
adventure and here Batman talks about
learning the value of friendship
Emmet tells Lucy about a nightmare that
he had with everyone he loved getting
sucked down into a dark pit which we
later learned was the bin of storage and
we get this shot of Gandalf falling from
a cliff this is a nod to Gandalf death
in the movie The Fellowship of the Ring
foods and afterimage shows off his new
dream house and his double-decker front
porch swing general mayhem arrives
she's voiced by Stephanie Beatrice and
rather than the classic lego person
design mayhem is taller more curved
she's from the LEGO Friends brand of
Legos that were marketed to girls the
weapons that mayhem fires at them are
stars and hearts just like the heart
that Emmet slash Finn gave to Bianca in
the beginning so really she's just
trying to return the love and if you
look closely you can see that some of
those hearts had visible thumb prints
and scratches on them a sign that these
are older
pieces with some more wear and tear
inside Batman's desert Batcave
mayhem kidnap several of them leaving an
image behind and Emma gets knocked down
he has a vision of the real world if you
listen closely you can hear them telling
Bianca that he's crafting a narrative
involving time travel it's a small
moment that foreshadows the reveal later
on that Rex danger vest is actually an
older version of Emmet from the future
travel back in time
Emmet gets chewed out by the others
including basketball stars Gary Payton
of the Seattle Sonics and Sheryl Swoopes
of WNBA team the Houston Comets now
swoops actually used to play in Seattle
as well for the storm lego movie
producers Phil Lord and Chris Miller are
from the Seattle area there's actually a
bunch of Seattle references throughout
this movie like the color palette of
wrecks danger vest and his ship and his
Raptors these are the Seahawks colors
now also in this cave there are a few
cameos from Velma from scooby-doo and
Harley Quinn of the Suicide Squad she
actually calls Emmett's plan a suicide
mission and Abraham Lincoln voiced by
Will Forte also returns in the first
movie and I love how his jetpack
Monument throne has been customized into
a game of Thrones iron throne
Gandalf makes a great joke here about
Marvel not returning their calls and
they're only superheros left our
old-school aquaman and unlicensed Larry
Poppins
now the lego movie properties are from
Warner Brothers animation and Warner
also has the rights to the DC Comics
characters Harry Potter characters Lord
the Rings which is why all those
characters can show up in this movie but
Marvel Star Wars Pixar those are all
owned by a different studio Disney which
is why those cameos can appear in movies
like wreckit-ralph 2 but it's harder for
them to get the rights in the lego movie
or in properties like ready player one
which is why you can see Iron Man in
that movie now there was a Star Wars
cameo in the first lego movie but that
was before Disney finalized its
acquisition of Lucasfilm general mayhem
brings the others to the sistar system
to meet Queen whatever one may be voiced
by Tiffany Haddish
she's a shapeshifter made up of
old-school diplo blocks the ones with
eyes and faces on them and and it
launches his rescue effort rebuilding
his house into a spaceship as he heads
out of the basement the door suspends
before him rotating as he calls it a
portal to dimensions unknown this is a
reference to the opening credits of The
Twilight Zone after flying through this
portal the ship blasts through with this
wormhole of multicolored light this door
is actually called this stair gate in
the
and all of this is also a nod to the
famous Stargate sequence from Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
it made a save from the asteroid field
by rekhs danger vest also voiced by
Chris Pratt since of course we find out
later
it's Emmitt from the future Rex is
basically an amalgam of various roles
that Chris Pratt has played galaxy
depending for star-lord and guardians of
the galaxy he jams out to motley crew as
he flies around in space and he mentions
having bad hearing from listening to a
mixtape at full volume of course nods to
the soundtrack of the Guardians movies
Rex also mentions having a chiseled
jawline hide it under Baby Phat
referencing the crazy change in Chris
Pratt's physical appearance when he
switched from Joey's sitcom star to
shredded superhero hashtag fat Pratt
you'll also notice that Pratt plays Rex
with a kind of vocal impersonation of
the actor Kurt Russell Kurt Russell
actually plays star Lord's father ego in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 who is
like Rex a friendly mentor figure who
later reveals himself as an evil
manipulator
Rex is also a cowboy reference to
Pratt's character in the reboot of the
Magnificent Seven a couple years ago so
a raptor trainer for his role as Owen
Grady in his dressing world movies has
he been doing these same pose with the
Raptors here he's also apparently an
archaeologist that could be a nod to the
speculation that Chris Pratt might be
being considered to play a young Indiana
Jones there's a photoshopped image that
went around a couple years ago it's just
insane to think that in the five years
since the first lego movie came out
Chris Pratt's career has taken off on
all of these different directions so I
don't blame them for using this as part
of the story another fun detail wrecks
the ship it's shaped like a punching
fist and the ship is called the wreck
celsior which could be a nod to excel
sue or the catchphrase of the late
Stanley meanwhile the rest of the crew
visits planet sparkles inhabited by
these sparkly vampires they describe
themselves as attractive non-threatening
teen vampires they talk about their
feelings and how they can never be
together
obviously these are parodies of the
vampires from the Twilight books and
movies they also describe this place as
a self reeducation celebrity center so
spiritual which is kind of veiled jab at
the Scientology celebrity center in
Hollywood
known for its creepy brainwashing coltie
reputation please don't sue me each of
them gets a makeover get scrubbed up
massage this is all very similar to the
Emerald
the sequence of The Wizard of Oz
actually Dorothy Scarecrow Tin Man and
the lion do show up a little later
Lucy's hair is revealed to be
multicolored and she takes it off when
she asks if she looks like Bruce Willis
and Bruce Willis shows up nearby sitting
on a hot tub Bruce Willis actually
voiced this part for the movie and Lucy
runs into him later while crawling
around the air ducts which is a nod to
willis's role as John McClane and die
hard meanwhile I'm anorexic Splore
another area and this whole part of the
movie is a giant homage to James Cameron
the weaponry that Rex and his Raptors
all suit up in is modeled on the mounted
machine guns at the Marines use and
aliens down to the tracking screens in
the drop ship that they use is just like
the Marines drop ship to the colony on
lv-426 and the way each Raptor gets
taken out one by one is just like how
the Xenomorphs take out the Marines also
Rex named one of these Raptors Ripley
the name of Sigourney Weaver's character
in the alien movies while another is
named Connor for John Connor or Sarah
Connor from The Terminator movies after
escaping Emmett and Rex spot this one
lone lamppost in the distance that could
be a nod to the lamppost of Narnia which
is the first marker that the kids find
and CS Lewis's The Lion the Witch and
the Wardrobe there's another reference
to CS Lewis that comes up later this
lamppost belongs to the cookie cutter
neighborhood where they run back into
the Justice League Jason Momoa returns
again as Aquaman saying General Zod just
made homemade guac Green Lantern says
he's a Zod send some of course is a
reference to General Zod the famous
Superman villain from Krypton he showed
up in Superman 2 and Man of Steel this
planet begins to brainwashed and culture
the newcomers with the breakout song
from this movie this songs gonna get
stuck inside your head the filmmakers
had to follow up the huge success of
everything is awesome from the first
movie a song that was nominated for an
Oscar by the way so they turned to Jon
Lajoie comedian a musician who's on the
show the league he also did that classic
viral song hi is Laura research the math
behind catchy pop songs
tsai-tien producer Max Martens and he
theorized that simple melodies that use
the same number of syllables per verse
hit the same notes repeat tend to be
catchy hits theirs while also mentioned
Radiohead a band who does this really
well they actually get a shout out in
this movie so then he submerged himself
in music influences like kpop Taylor
Swift songs he reached out to t-pain to
do the vocals for this and then he
doubled up t-pain's harmonies with
fourth and fifth layers just like
Katy Perry doesn't her songs and then he
brought in that girl Lele to rap the
verses after seeing her perform on Ellen
mixed it all together and then BAM here
you go catchy brainwashing your worm
and by the way Liz Ross said that he
pitched alternate ideas for this song
one called
it's hard to follow up a hit song in a
slightly tweaked version of everything
is awesome called
it's all amazing anyway as Rex and
Emmett flee Rex says think hard thoughts
the rhythm is gonna get you it's a
reference to the catchy Gloria Estefan
song and then after they escape right is
this movie it's it's halfway mark it
abruptly cuts to this intermission reel
with banana or ice cream cone and
chocolate bar this is a parody of the
let's all go to the lobby cartoon that
would air midway through screenings of
old-timey movies or if you go to the
Vista theater in LA my favorite place to
see movies it rolls at the beginning of
every show jumping ahead to the scene
with Batman and queen whatever maybe who
sings that she's just not into Gotham
City guys the song that is filled with
Batman references all the actors who
have played live-action Batman get
mentioned she sings I ain't no Selena
Kyle I ain't no Vicki Vale I was never
into you even when you were Christian
Bale and Batman goes I'm more of a
Keaton guy myself
then later Batman says he's Affleck
level hot and he has George Clooney
charm and val kilmer lips and that he
used to wear tights just ask Adam West
Rex and Emmet plot to wreck the wedding
ceremony which is actually orchestrated
by the sister Bianca as a way to make
peace with her brother obviously a plan
that didn't work and Rex backflips away
and lands on Wonder Woman's invisible
jet he hijacks it Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg makes a cameo during
this ceremony which of course Emmet Rex
leading to him learning the truth about
Rex and his time-travel backstory
Rex mentions having gathered pieces from
a number of pop-culture Time Traveller's
we see Doc Brown of a DeLorean from Back
to the Future later we see the flux
capacitor from that time machine he also
breaks up the phone booth from Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure
the TARDIS from Doctor Who and HG Wells
bicycle thing and onto the steampunky
Time Machine from Wells novel Rex also
breaks up whatever Skynet was using he
boots that metal skeleton this is again
referencing the killer cyborgs from the
Terminator who travel back in time
annie breaks up a hot tub a reference to
the movie Hot Tub Time Machine Rex
lectures Emma he mentions the matrix of
grown-up movie that a little cool kids
like him watch and then Rex
time to put away childish things it's a
very interesting quote this is another
nod to Chronicles of Narnia authors CS
Lewis who famously quoted the Bible time
to put away childish things
but then Lewis added including the fear
of childishness and the desire to be
very grown-up so even though Rex is
attempting to sound serious with this
Bible quote he's actually undercutting
his own seriousness by accidentally
alluding to the opposing view that it's
okay to embrace your inner child and not
grow up Maya Rudolph cameos is the kid's
mom
orders them to put their Legos into
storage mama get in comes true Abe
Lincoln screams I had theater tickets
tonight the reference to Lincoln's
famous assassination during a play after
a fake-out ending the abandoned Legos
lay sadly in storage and they all began
to sadly sing everything's not awesome
actually Lego teamed up with Greenpeace
to put out a similar depressing cover
for a PSA warning about climate change
in pollution
[Music]
but they all rally and defeat rex
reflecting the peace between Finn and
Bianca
Rex fades from existence back to the
future and as he calls it though the way
it goes piece by piece looks a bit more
like that time travel existence fading
for movies like looper frequency and as
a brother and sister play in the
backyard we get one last callback the
voice of Will Ferrell who couldn't
appear physically on set for this movie
he only recorded vocals and he shouts
the line honey where are my pants that
of course is the catchphrase from an
Emmett and president business's favorite
sitcom in the first movie what was your
favorite cameo in lego movie too comment
down below with your thoughts and follow
me on twitter and instagram @ ee vas and
subscribe to this channel and subscribe
to our podcast wherever you listen to
podcasts thank you for watching and oh
oh my god okay
I forgot it I forgot that the stupid
catchy song it's out of my head I'm free
I could sleep wait a minute this song is
gonna get stuck inside yeah